ます
ああああああ
ブービー4回生 day
サーファーらいいなというふうなんですけどもブーバー大学に入ってからキャーキャー
ぬーっ
そんなのかって話よちょっと皆さん紹介したいなと思います
今ここに書いてある通りで今日というの陰謀るメガネーということなんですけど
p ポールは皆さん遊んだとかありますか
按分の細ありがとう
あのー
ブーバで受けたあぁ私のぬふ
手動ですよその2つ路線はで極めさせていただきます
はいこれは
良いものです
いい
はいで文書も共じゃあ私ものピンボールでも事実なんですけど私はちょうど様から3年
万円でも4回シャイで1回て入ったときのちょうどもっとこの時期です
めっちゃ困ってて
まあ何かというと
素の自分がこう肌が入ったはいいんですけどもよくありますこの思いつき処方
ねえ経験2 b そうな顔いるんですけどまぁか言った絵が入ってからないでしょう
からすごいをやっていて
でその時にこま私のそうですねこっさまでボールで最初パンって言うんですけど
その花咲く
奴の原則的にどんどんナレーションってすごい
フック少しと時期がありましたでその時に私が最初にぶつかった瓶っていうのがあって
でもそれを統括するんですけどその時は
風セルフの経済豊田仮想敗となりますこの授業をしたときに
あのーもう一人の人がやっていたんですねの授業が始まる授業前コートと携帯をいじり
ながらどうしようと思って
この私がまあその暇を敷いたら今年でいたですが国家っていつ
こんな感じで高生背負って入ってきて
を何だと思ったら朝日豊田康インターンシップの上階の新規だろう
を夏休みにを大学生が文議員の下でそのいろんな社会体験を症っていうプログラムが
あるからまぁこれどうですかっていう話を
まあ紹介してくれましたでが者はびっくりして
パティてもうちょっとすっごい寸皿あれなんですけどここずこんな剛性も入り込ん
シャーリングでどうぞと喋って
でマーサっと颯爽とか言ったソロさてパサーシップ
インターン別にそんな興味なかったんですけどそういう人になれるんだったら欲しいと
言うところさ
いいターンありかなと思って立ったのがこのひとつ目の荒瀬とっているころ
反射感 new じゃなく勇者の壁だったんですね
まあそのてその人の右から行けますのインターンシップを参加したんですけどまぁその
参加してからすごいすごい変わって代引き回生の時はどういうか
まあすごいつまんないなーという感じだ
ウェイターシップ始まってからあマジかと思って
何が楽しかったって言うとがその員のことでインターンシップをするんですけど
まあ議員の一味女としてももっと h
違うことであってこれが自分の打ったリーグでお皿背負って家族と宣誓しあったんです
けどパーそろそろ
ね頑張っているとその人は東風生き様をしてみたかったとかそういう話はすっごいまり
つけて私にとってはすごい
一回戦ですから来なそうそうですかなと思って
まあ大谷車ん
それは付属のまずは後ろそのキーポイントというか
ピンポイントた山笠のか撮ってここに神上がってきてもそれは私が一緒だったんです
けどそれが終わってからまたそのあるの
大切に港航路とば車どんなコプシュって戻ると思うけど本当にオタク次のかでどう
なるかっていうのところに無茶なりました
それなりに貼って言ったらも苦手つが終わってからもう1回でのあっきーですよね
旅からじゃあこのどうしようとなって阿蘇のウェイターショップ自体の
そのスタッフをするかどうかっていうところ
私が4普通授業を受ければに行った時にこうやってきた1グラムに今のスタッフとして
これを自分が経験したものをその人にほど届けていこうというのでスタートしヨーカ
ドーマンっていう選択の一つあったんですけど
非常にやりましたね
ブーバーしっ2カ月間見て下さってたサティ
まあその人がいつもメール送れてきれいこういいとかってまぁ
もなつまりをご一緒に散歩や編みたいなもらって
押さメールを見て初めてあーじゃあここまでないんだったらやろうってポロスター
てバンパー設定まあ八段下がっています
page ルって非常に正二やることが多い大変だったんですけど
まあその中で
やっぱり大変だったらぞ
ブービー以下青いかあっに指揮者
がここに足を運んでくださったのも何かしらのきっかけがあったんだと思うんですけど
あの
自分はやりていくと自分の人生というのはピカも人によってした変わらないなと思って
ふーんだか
このテーマご自分が子すごい決意の朝みって歌われるけどその何か決意をするけれども
まぁだいたいで次のに起きたらだいたい一見ムッチしないですか
恐る er ションっていうかじゃないけど
あそいでまぁその人を自分が矛盾がどう変わるか立ち上が同池てきてどう変わっていく
かというのはやっぱ自分がつきゃでしょか
極まれて待ってクイッター自分その人ではない自分は変わらないんだなことにすごい
思って
ましたねなので私はそうインターンの参加してもスタッフをして最終的に代表という
立場とかもそうしてもらったんですけど私は
入学した時とか本はいつもの前声でしゃべるの
わー結構絶対イプロスだったんで
それ以降人とは絶対思わなかったんですけどそこにその
行った人たちと考え方とかそこで経験したことによって母校の兵法
1回いただいてはた会社だったんですけど
まあ第1子はどうやらそうですねその ping 攻撃っていう話を得られないという
か来るともうあたしたちはこの魂なんですよね
またはディをステートの壁に当たって言ったら言って本当に
ぱ自分の進む道とかマーサー方向であったりとか参加加速であったいっていうのは
すごい変わってくるなんて言うので5話
いやだからま一つ大事にし誘惑すごいその月雨でもあるんですけどもすごい
powwow 食器付けたのがこの活動としていたことかなと思う
はいねえもう一つのですね
メガネ岡部てるかだ
本来のカラー
本も選んにしてるんですか
あ
いやそう私はこういったんですけどはい
でマートっ子へなぜ言いたかっですねそのメガネをかけること
別ねぇまぁいいんですけど今度は自分でも
いやここははないかというとこの私はそのは前世ピンボールじゃんって思う中でパーン
を叱って
なぁこれわかるほどって持ったことなんですけど
8まあこれを
そうですこれはご存じですからのちょっともなんですか
言います闇で私姫路姫路出身なんで一年以上にしようか迷ったんですけどオスここ大阪
なんでに安保ときました
で
まあまあこれを多さがちょうど普通に見たら江寧
見えるんですけどどうドン王
これは何かというと
メガネをかけて見てるのでも普通ワード合う野郎っていうところなんですけどそうで
なくてこれは近いの自分にどうってないよねつまり1合う人のメガネを食べているから
まあこうなってるんですね
まあつまりですパンツはじゃないですあの形はあの私をこのスタッフを忘れてからまず
このメインとなった仮装っていうのはこの子の自分にしスタッフとして今に
インターンシップなるんですよよこのまたの判断間に雇用長くに届けていくっていうの
を一つの大きな活動でした
ん
で最初はその自分ば自身がこうインターンの通してすごい
この買われたっていうか
here と思ってるんでまぁソロ3ですけどまぁを聞い協力表と数十にょそういう
いうところに行ってたのでまぁやってるともそしたらもの中何言ってるかわかんない
よっていて私はこの人にインターンシップを進めては良い一かけ作りをしてほしいんだ
けれども
まあでまぁそりゃああーしくって
にょろ接写8位
そういう感じでこう進めるようになっている自分があって
まあねそんな子センター翼を
ピンポンってあるんですか開けちゃですがセールスマンはクマ
このまた損害であればこそ実感や時成立は何も来なかったんですけど
足を突っ込んセルさんみたいな非常にうっとうし
村内になったと思う
ブーブーいきたいけどもそれは自分の試合が自分の目線でしかあー市久代サティ
もあるんですけどまぁそれを考えてみようからてつもりやってる10発すごいすごい
そのもうそこされるとこう聞くじゃないですか補助選手の皆様なんか
荒天時行為すっごいはれたらちょっと引くじゃないですか
私は1分こーされるからは日目です
いや挑むしてるもんだこれまたの自分の目線食べての店立良いって言うの数学その
スタッフ生活している中で痛感しました
巨でへ
まあこれは何が言いたいかというとその相手の目がにをかけること
ブービー一緒に行かあそろそろ最初
だいたいそうでしょんですけどじゃあ
ソニョそう
お姐はてぃどうしたらいいかあずきかあっあの
ブーブー言うけど image here
てそしようって言うんじゃなくて朝この方はこういうことに興味がありましたこれこう
やった達成できるよっていうふうにこう相手は何を求めてるのかっていうのもそれを後
を引かない限りは何もできないなと思って
私はこの時
ブーブー言ってるんですけどブーバしてからそろそろ西行きたいよてょてょ緑化すって
いう
するとそしてやっぱり相手の心もやっぱりこっちを置いてくれるんですよ英語では
インターン
すごくその子にとっては何か良いインターンシップの参加を過ごしてくる人っていう
存在だったのはそこから
koa 自分の悩みを解決してくれる人っていうこのコーナーです私はこういうことし
たいった漁っ
蛸井手段で解決できるよっていう風にできますよという風な考え方っていうのを一つ
持ってたのは私はこのスタッフ
至るスタッフ海スタッフをする上で得たこと
no キャットで
ですねー
このデー
であーこれはあのーブーツは靴も昨年もあるんですけどやっぱ積まれた仕掛けを伝え
たいことっていうのは結局はコーチとこのだしたちっこいきている道っていうのは
ことを言う人と関わってその人とどういう関係をつくって言ったかそれでしか買われ
ないこの
今
のやつ話し合いか違ってねー近くあってまぁそこん所にぶつかるパンやって自分が不
サウジって本当に変わってくるかと思っていて
そんなでこれが投資だんだんもちろん上が買いたいなとか思うことがあったら
補正アバンその付き合う人であったりとかておりはつけてる人と動物買うかっていうの
を
それを履いていることが自分の勝手打つなよ700系ではすごく私は多摩テックせいか
と思って通してもらったことでドーン
ブーブしイカロス使っていく人と相対する時にこの意識する夏の it のパティ
背負ったああっ
より良いより良いより良いてぃ多数宇宙的なんですよねそういうこと言い関係やくれて
おはそのきっかけでは違う
モールの日がどんどん変わっていいかもしれないなっていうところねまぁその点ボール
と
目はね
ブーブーっていうか阿蘇の恐竜ドゥーリー恐れを意識しながら言うと
コミュ力 watch 分の一字つ折り所
なって思いましたのではいというところで私のメッセージとしてはハイ眼鏡をかけ
ましょう
っていう事でコンタクトもおすすめですはい平和的本当に色設定もありがとうござい
ました